winter found-footage movies gonna die
why can't they just die Devils do tell
I'm happy I'm even talking about this
movie so Devils do is another found
footage movie where someone's recording
all the happenings in his life for his
unborn sons as his wife's pregnant and
weird starts happening from that
synopsis alone you know exactly what the
movies gonna be like I you not
weird things start happening lights
start flickering she starts standing
there like this just looking at nothing
for a really long time well lucky this
movie is only one hour 28 minutes long
right it's not gonna feel long oh my god
this movie felt so long I am
hopscotching through my points here hold
on let me get back on track let me focus
this movie is proof positive that you
become an idiot when you get married
because these two are stupid they're on
their honeymoon and this really shady
cab drivers like Heil take you somewhere
really special really nice well it's not
really nice out in the middle of nowhere
but it's really cool you're gonna love
it and they drive into the middle of
nowhere and they're going down an alley
down some stairs down another dark alley
you look around there's a boarded up
windows everywhere I would be out I'd be
like you know what I'm out of here
because I like my life but these
follow him into this basement
into this club and after that it just
gets bad it's actually the most
interesting part of the movie is the
fact that there is some weird secret
underground thing happening here they're
being followed and people are watching
them that's scarier than the stupid I
don't know demon possession fetus
whatever is haunting them but even at
that point even the cop is stupid in
this movie because the people sprinkle
ash everywhere and he's like i'm calling
9-1-1 so this cop comes over in the cops
like hold on just me i can only write a
report that's it Makai feels like he has
no answers he's like but officer things
this is bad just people are watching us
and they're vandalizing my house the
cops like look I'll make a report all
right I gotta go I just don't think the
cop would leave the guy with no answers
whatsoever just I was like no that's not
a cop that's a shitty actor in a bad
movie not gonna lie I'm gonna have a
couple of spoilers in this video but
it's Sunday if you wanted to see the
movie by now you've seen the movie if
you didn't want to see the movie I'm
gonna tell you why you shouldn't see the
movie so yeah a couple spoilers out of
the norm for me but we're doing what
we're doing to keep this video fun you
want the biggest loophole in the entire
movie here it is is the fact that it's
even a found footage movie at the
the beginning of the movie shows the
husband and he's all like bleeding and
he's twiddling with his wedding ring and
the cops like so why'd you do it man
why'd you do it he's like I didn't do it
then it goes back and shows what
happened that he said he didn't do and
you have no doubt whatsoever that he is
innocent but here's the thing
it's a found footage movie found being
the operative word in that title that's
the magic of found-footage movies that
is supposed to be real like you're
watching you're like oh everyone knows
about they found these tapes or memory
sticks because that's what they record
on now and the timestamp when the cop is
talking to the guy is March 2013 I'm
like okay let's say these tapes were
found last month and now it's gotten a
theatrical release for the magic of
bound footage movies pretty sure that
due to be off the hook now what he
suffered for about nine months were
people thinking he was an did
the trial even go through at that point
I'm just saying he'll be fine I wanted
to say the end was cool because it
looked cool cuz was getting thrown
around the house but that's like saying
transformers 2 is cool because a lot of
gets thrown around in there so yeah
the fact that gets thrown around a
house and a found footage movie doesn't
impress me
just like 3ds no longer impressive just
like D box is no longer impressive just
like found-footage movies in general are
not impressive on the basis that they're
just found footage movies gimmicks wear
down over time they wear down to nothing
and that's what found-footage is now
it's nothing I grab them about the fact
that this is a found footage movie
because at a point in watching this
movie I stepped out of myself and I was
like what if this wasn't a found footage
movie what would it be like and it would
be better and I'm saying it would be
great I'm just saying if it was a movie
that was not a found footage movie like
insidious sinister or something like
that it would be better than it was here
everyone is supposed to be a creep in
this movie is obviously creep in this
movie she has an ob/gyn nice lady and
then later on in the movie this really
shady ass doctor comes in he's like I'm
sorry your normal ob/gyn she will not be
with us anymore she had to take a long
vacation then with the whole
interrogation scene with the cops
talking to the guy at the very very end
of the movie which is a continuation
from the first shot of the movie they're
like dr. Dylan or whatever his name was
doesn't even work at that hospital you
made him up I'd be like all right then
who did we see that day obviously
there's a hospital record or what
happened to the other ob/gyn you want to
look into that ask her she obviously
wasn't a part of the plan otherwise she
would have been the ob/gyn that was
keeping tabs on us
to talk to her worst case scenario she's
gonna be like yeah I never saw them that
day or other case scenario you never
find her because she's rotten in a
barrel somewhere point is loopholes
friends Lou
holes and just takes me out of the
movie and I'm like who wrote this well
really put it over the edge of no
salvation for me is the fact that this
movie felt so long it was so boring
right along felt a lot shorter than this
moving right along the half an hour
longer than Devils do I come back to
this simple fact Paranormal Activity the
marked ones was a better movie than
Devil's Due so I gotta say Devil's Due
simply is dog or so Devils do have
you seen it what did you think about it
if you saw it because I didn't do a
video yet I'm really sorry I had a busy
weekend things were happening just
family stuff and well here it is better
late than never
sorry you wasted ten bucks whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more